Ramona Shelburne the great in NBA
insider from the mothership joining us
as I mentioned Ramona will be on the
jumps NBA free agency special on Sunday
and Monday 7:00 Eastern on espn2 it's a
delight to have you on Ramona how are
you this morning
good good I guess today is one of the
one of the days we've been waiting to
hear right today is one of the big we
find out if he if LeBron opts into his
contractor or just employee what's the
deadline passed by which is what we all
expect to happen but and then I think
that's the real official start right
like there's been this sort of pre
period but after that that's the real
official start to best-case scenario for
the Lakers is what and over the next
about two weeks three weeks the best
case would be just you know the the the
original plan stick holds up right they
get LeBron and Paul George and then they
figure out something to do you know with
it with with another star or somewhere
in between but I think they feel like I
think there's a sense right now that the
original plan is is not in play right
now
I hate because Paul George seems to be
staying in Oklahoma City leads us all
the indications everybody seems to have
right now and still I have certainly as
a recorder I'm talking to people and so
that's why you see all the wildness
you've seen this last week where you
know you sort of have to this is a
truism we found in the NBA the last few
years which is simply you have to get
one star before you can get to and you
have to get to is where you even think
about three no they don't they don't
have any of those they have a bunch of
kids who play really you know a nice
brand of basketball but and they have a
lot of cap space but it's hard to get
somebody be the first and I think that's
that's where they are right now but if
LeBron would opt out and go to the
Lakers the Lakers are still going to
have to give up a treasure trove to get
Kawhi there it how good are the Lakers
going to be if you have LeBron and Kawhi
like what's going to be less there yeah
I mean I think that's where you look and
say okay look Ryan have a lot of guys in
the rolodex right you have a lot of
dudes who you
you know call Bob see if they'll come to
the vet minimum call may happen but
that's that's not ideal and I think
that's where you know they look at it
and I think the Lakers have a big
picture sense of this too which is you
know they they they don't you know there
is a fair trade to make for Kawhi
Leonard it out there but it's your
whoever's definition of fair right if
you're San Antonio fare as well as you
get to Y that that's sort of like
trading for LeBron and Kawhi and so they
want a lot and you know the Lakers are
sort of saying you know well the last
couple of trades that have happened in
this in this vein have been something
like two quick young players and maybe a
drastic right and so you you sure use
the models of the last couple of trades
and you know and and sort of see how
this plays out and I think we're at the
point now where somebody's either going
to blink or they're not and we're not
going to see it much action but they do
have a lot of other options and I think
people sometimes laser focus in on one
option with the Kawhi Leonard option
because that's what's been reported and
that's what seems obvious right now but
there's so many other players in the
league especially in a league that's
still dealing with the fallout from
people signing massive contracts two
years ago when it was a salary cap spike
and then now there's really not a lot of
now there's not a lot of money out there
well when you have two spots open in
terms of starter cap space for a maximum
contracts you can trade somebody into
that space it's not necessarily you
don't have to necessarily find a
creative show somebody that space so
there's a lot of players out there who
are available that you know are more
available than people realize that's
right and and I think that'll be
interesting to see how it plays out over
the next next couple weeks because your
free agency is is one thing and then
there's the the post freeze and see what
people find out okay what not aware
really no no well that's no fun Ramona
that this is the fun part here is it's
like the speculation the rumor innuendo
is what's fun if I made you come
that you could say this is where LeBron
is going to go for the good of the
league where would you have LeBron James
go or stay well listen I I would say LA
or Cleveland because but if I had to
choose and and and so I'm the
Commissioner or I'm me because of what I
I normally route from me right how'd you
get on a lot of airplanes the last
couple of years because the Lakers and
Clippers have not been all that relevant
yeah so when I root for me I root for
the team in LA better for me to have a
good team but you know what I've kind of
got to the point where like I enjoy that
I I have enjoyed the story and I've
enjoyed the circus and the Cleveland
Cavaliers have been a heck of a story
and a heck of a circus and I I think you
know right as a writer like sometimes
people get frustrated writing about the
same thing over and over and over it's
four straight years of the same finals
right no I I got into it sort of I
wouldn't I wouldn't hate it if he stayed
in Cleveland either because it's sort of
it it's a nice story and it would be a
surprising turn at this point yeah I'm
in the minority I've been saying all
along that he stays there one more year
just to kind of get a better sense of
what's happening and I don't I don't
think he wants to join the Lakers a year
early and with these kids and they are
kids I think he'd like to see what
happens with that 2019 free agency class
and then maybe he can orchestrate it a
little bit better
there's too much unknown right now for
him too
- I think disco I'm all-in on the Lakers
whether we get somebody or not your
thoughts on that yeah yeah I I don't I
don't disagree with you in terms of the
thought process there and I think it's
you know when you're LeBron James a star
that's the stature right like it's
really transcendent star you don't take
a pitch meeting unless you already know
what you're going to do right like you
must you know the answers yes like he
wants to do a a film project and you're
going to have a meeting with some
studios you're not stepping in and and
thinking to any kind of may into any
time meeting and think there's a chance
they may not
your your project right like by the time
you get in that room you know with the
solid so it's kind of saving this for
agency right you're that good you don't
necessarily need to be taking risk he's
he's done so much in his career he
doesn't need to be the guy taking on the
risk and yet I think that's the position
he's in right now you know and and some
of it is up to him right some of it is
you know he's got that like I said he's
got the role with ex with every play in
the league and you know as much as
everybody thinks it's about teams
recruiting players it's really at this
stage in the NBA players recruiting
players and so I think he has a little
more control over the situation than any
of us realized we're just you know not
not privy to all the behind-the-scenes
texting and snap chatting and facetiming
Ramona I know you got a busy weekend
there thanks for joining us and we
appreciate your time you got it
that's a Ramona shelburne ESPN NBA
insider for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]